Ladies, getting your groove back might not
require a trip to Jamaica!
A Female sex drive pill might be here very
soon.
Hello everyone!
Amy with you on DNews today.
Sildenafil - sold under the trade name “Viagra”
- might be the most well-known pill on the
market, and while almost everyone knows that
it’s used to treat sexual disorders like
erectile disfunction, not everyone knows how
it works.
Viagra does not cause sexual arousal in men.
It only works if the man is aroused, and in
that case it helps that arousal along by managing
the chemistry that causes a man to get an
erection.
Specifically, it maintains the levels of messenger
cyclic guanosine monophosphate that stimulates
erectile tissue.
But sexual disfunction works a little differently
for women.
Though some are physical, many female sexual
disorders come down to mental and emotional
factors leading to disinterest in sex and
an overall low sex drive, properly called
hypoactive sexual desire disorder.
Arousal and disinterest in sex are still somewhat
unknown to scientists, although they do know
that the brain’s circuitry is involved.
One theory is that low sex drive results from
an inability to switch off the frontal parts
of the brain that manage everyday tasks, mundane
things like remembering to go to the post
office or resolve a problem at work.
With these frontal parts switched on, the
reward circuitry that managed motivation and
pleasure is left inhibited.
And this means women can’t really get into
sex.
But there’s a weird silver lining.
Like erectile disfunction in men, low sex
drive is chemical, and that is something treatable.
The female version of the little blue pill
is called Flibanserin and it’s currently
pending approval by the FDA (there’s a meeting
to decide its fate early next month).
Flibanserin was initially developed as an
antidepressant, but while women in a clinical
trial didn’t notice a change in mood, they
did find themselves more interested in sex.
It was dropped as an antidepressant and refocused
to treat women’s waning libido.
This drug, it seems, tweaks the balance of
key neurotransmitters dopamine, noradrenaline,
and serotonin, either normalising levels or
compensating for imbalances to bring these
circuits back to optimal levels, disengage
the frontal circuits that inhibit sex drive.
And while the women who tried it didn’t
see a massive result, they still noticed a
positive trend.
Of course, measuring an improvement is pretty
hard.
It seems women don’t have a lot of sex on
average, just three times per month.
During the trial, women on Flibanserin had
about 2.5 sexual events in four weeks while
women not on the drug with low sex drive had
just one and a half sexual event per month.
Of course, there are other factors that affect
a woman’s sex drive, like self-esteem issues
and disinterest in a relationship, and these
aren’t necessarily things that should be
dealt with medically.
And sex drive does wane with age, though this
does vary between individuals.
Some women experience a marked drop in sex
drive after menopause while others may experience
a renewed sexual awakening.
But if a younger woman is in an otherwise
loving relationship, Flibanserin, if it passes
by the FDA, could be the boon for women that
Viagra has been for men.
And if you do have more sex, maybe it could
lead to more money.
Julia explores that finding in this DNews
video here